my opinion however is that the origin of
so great a city and an empire next in
power to that of the gods was due to the
fates the Vestal Ray was ravished by
force and having brought forth twins
declared Mars to be the father of her
illegitimate offspring either because
she really imagined it to be the case or
because it was less discreditable to
have committed such an offense with a
god but neither God's nor men protected
either her or her offspring from the
Kings cruelty
the priestess was bound and cast into
prison the king ordered the children to
be thrown into the flowing river by some
chance which providence seemed to direct
the Tiber having overflown its banks
thereby forming stagnant pools could not
be approached at the regular course of
its channel notwithstanding it gave the
bearers of the children hope that they
could be drowned in its water however
come accordingly as if they had executed
the King's orders they exposed the boys
in the nearest land pool where now
stands the thickest who Romulus at that
time the country in those parts was a
desolate wilderness the story goes that
when the shallow water subsiding had
left the floating trough in which the
children had been exposed on dry ground
a thirsty she-wolf from the mountains
around to directed her course towards
the cries of the infants and held down
her teats to them with such gentleness
that the keeper of the Kings herd found
her licking the boys with her tongue
they say that his name was Faust Ulis
and they were carried by him to his
homestead and given to his wife Lauren
Tia to be brought up some were of the
opinion that Loretta was called lupa
among the Shepherds from her being a
common prostitute and Henson opening was
afforded for the marvelous story the
children thus born and thus brought up
as soon as they reached the age of youth
did not lead a life of inactivity at
home or amid the flocks but in the chase
scoured the forests having thus gained
strength both in body and spirit they
now were not only able to withstand wild
beasts but attacked robbers laden with
booty and divided the spoils with the
Shepherd's in his company as the number
of their young associates increased
daily they carried on business and
pleasure even in these early times it is
said that the festival of the Lupo Cal
has now celebrated was solemnized on the
Palatine Hill which was first called :
tiem from palan tiem a city of arcadia
and afterward mount pilatus there
Evander who belonging to the above tribe
of the Arcadians who had for many years
before occupied these districts is said
to have appointed the observance of a
solemn festival introduced from Arcadia
in which naked youths ran about doing
honor in wanton sport to pan the chaos
who was afterward called Ennis by the
Romans when they were engaged in this
festival as its periodical Solomon
ization was well known a band of robbers
enraged at the loss of some booty lay in
wait for them and took Remus prisoner
Romulus having vigorously defended
himself the captive Remus they delivered
up to King Amulius
and even went so far as to bring
accusations against him they made it the
principal charged having made incursions
into Numa tours lands and having
assembled a band of young men they had
driven off their booty after the manner
of
enemies accordingly Remus was delivered
up to Numa tour for punishment now from
the very first Faust Tillis had
entertained hopes that the boys who were
being brought up by him were of royal
blood for he both knew that the children
had been exposed by the King's orders
and that the time at which he had taken
them up coincided exactly with that
period but he had been unwilling to
disclose the matter as yet not ripe for
discovery till either a fitting
opportunity or the necessity for it
should arise necessity came first
accordingly urged by fear he disclosed
the whole affair to Romulus by accident
also Numa tour while he had Remus in
custody having heard that the brothers
were twins by comparing their age and
the natural disposition entirely free
from servility felt his mind struck by
the recollection of his grandchildren
and by frequent inquiries came to the
conclusion he had already formed so that
he was not far from openly acknowledging
Remus accordingly a plot was concerted
against the King on all sides
Romulus not accompanied by a body of
young men for he was not equal to open
violence but having commanded the
shepherds to come to the palace by
different roads a fixed time made an
attack upon the King while Remus having
got together another party from nuuma
tors house came to his assistance and so
they slew the King
NUMA tour at the beginning of a fray
giving out that enemies had invaded the
city and attacked the palace after he
had drawn off the urban youth to the
Citadel to secure it with an armed
garrison
when he saw the young men after they had
come past the King's death advancing
towards him to offer congratulations
immediately summoned a meeting of the
people and recounted his brother's
unnatural behavior towards him the
extraction of his grandchildren and the
manner of their birth bringing up and
recognition and went on to inform them
of the Kings death and that he was
responsible for it the young prince's
advanced through the midst of the
assembly with their band in order the
array and after they had saluted their
grandfather as king a succeeding shout
of approbation issuing from the whole
multitude ratified for him the name and
authority of sovereign the government of
Alba being thus entrusted to nuuma tour
Romulus and Remus were seized with the
desire of building a city on the spot
where they had been exposed and brought
up indeed the number of Alban and Latin
inhabitants was too great for the city
and all these readily inspired hopes
that Alba and Lavinia would be
insignificant in comparison with that
city which was intended to be built but
desire of rule the bane of their
grandfather interrupted these designs
and thence arose a shameful quarrel from
a sufficiently amicable beginning for as
they were twins and consequently the
respect for seniority could not settle
the point they agreed to leave it to the
gods and the whose protection the place
was to choose by augury which of them
should give a name to the new city and
govern it when built Romulus chose the
Palatine and Remus the Aventine has
points of observation for taking the
auguries
[Music]
it is said that an omen came to Remus
first six vultures and when after the
omen had been declared twice that number
presented themselves to Romulus each was
hailed king by his own party
the former claiming sovereign power on
the ground of priority of time the
latter on account of the number of birds
thereupon having met and exchanged angry
words from the strife of angry feelings
they turned to bloodshed there Remus
fell from a blow received in the crowd a
more common account is that Remus in the
vision of his brother leaped over the
newly erected walls and was thereupon
slain by Romulus in a fit of passion who
mocking him added words to this effect
so perish everyone hereafter who shall
leap over my walls thus Romulus obtained
possession of supreme power for himself
alone the city when built was called
after the name of its founder
[Music]
you